so this next story is ironic funny and
sad at the same time a Texas teacher was
fired for trying to report undocumented
students to the President of the United
States before I read her tweets let me
read the quote from NBC News to give you
the background quote the Forth Worth
Independent School District unanimously
voted eight to zero to terminate the
employment of Georgia Clarke and a
special meeting Tuesday Clarke an
English teacher at Carter Riverside High
School tweeted that the school she
worked for had been taken over by
illegal students from Mexico that Trump
was elected on the promise that a wall
would be built to protect our borders
and tweeted multiple statements
referencing illegals but it kids better
or worse depending on how you view this
story she said quote she was suspended
of the article rather said quote she was
suspended in 2013 after she allegedly
referred to a group of students as
little Mexico and another student as
white bread park is also under
investigation for a complaint that she
allegedly told a student to quote show
me your papers you are illegal after the
student asked permission to go to the
bathroom according to the district
documents Clark told an investigator she
thought the tweets were a direct message
to President Trump and didn't know they
were public that's the part that is so
delicious the fact that she so smart
with her bigotry that she didn't even
know how to use the system that ended up
leading to her firing now you can we
could quibble over whether or not she
should have lost her job over this over
the tweets but you can't really quibble
over whether or not she should have been
in the classroom in the first place like
looking at her history there's there's
really no reason that this type of
person should be in a classroom anywhere
in this country not only because of her
bigotry but also because of her level of
ignorance I mean there's a level of
ignorance here that really screams out
I'm not qualified to teach anybody
[Laughter]
but she found out the hard way I want to
pull up the tweets on your screen so
that you could see what she said it's a
series of tweets that she sent clearly
identifying herself trying honestly to
report the undocumented students then it
didn't really work out too well for her
this is what she said on Twitter
back in May she said quote mr. president
Fort Worth Independent School District
is loaded with illegal students from
Mexico
Carter Riverside High School has been
taken over by them
drug dealers are on our campus and
nothing was done to them when drug dogs
found the evidence Donald Trump could
you please remind the Democrats that a
majority of the people elected you no
they didn't but I digress could you
please remind the Democrats that a
majority of the people elected you on
the promise that a wall would be built
to protect our borders just how many of
us voted for you shouldn't we the people
count for something I I love I'm sorry
Peck cut back to me I love I love how
she's like really making an earnest plea
here I don't even know if the rest of
the tweets are worth reading I just want
to pause and and talk about how genuine
this woman is with her bigotry like that
last line oh no actually you do have to
show these tweets I'm sorry it gets
better
she said and that last line shouldn't we
the people count for something and then
the next tweet is my prayers were
answered drain that swamp and the sooner
the better I mean folks I I don't like
to revel in in people's destruction but
man the irony that it is it is just how
are you so genuine about being watch my
mouth I'm on David show a jerk a bigot
like from the depths of our heart
she really is pouring out to what she
thought was a direct message to the
president but public on Twitter she's
genuinely pouring out her bigotry
I'm sorry I want me to be so dramatic
but that's really something it reminds
me of the story I don't know if it's
been covered I maybe I should cover it
because I'll just mention it here the
story of the little seven-year-old boy
in Texas who raised $22,000 to to help
Donald Trump build a wall and he raised
it by selling hot chocolate in Texas in
June and somebody tweeted on Twitter
they said you've got to be one hell of a
racist to buy hot chocolate in June in
Texas
I mean I'm laughing but we maybe should
we should be crying because look at the
level of commitment that these morons
have to their bigotry she's so committed
and so well no she was genuine and so
committed but but but but the story of
the of the of the hot chocolate is
really about the commitment where you're
willing to go out there and drink hot
chocolate in a hundred degree weather in
Texas these people are so dedicated to
their bigotry and and and I really drive
that point home because there's no
there's no working with them man there's
there's no reaching across the aisle to
them I know I know I'm not sure where
David stands on that so I can't really
say whether David thinks we should reach
across the aisle or not I got it maybe
I'll go watch them as videos but for me
in my house you know when somebody is so
dedicated to their bigotry that they're
willing to drink hot chocolate in Texas
at 100 degree weather to help build a
wall there's really no reasoning with
them there's no there's no trying to
explain something and win them over it
just becomes an exercise in futility in
in my best estimation so this woman was
fired I'm sorry for laughing so much at
her for being fired not so much at her
for being fired but but because of the
sincerity of her bigotry I've never seen
it's like it's like as hard as we fight
as genuine as we fight to help liberate
people and help set them free and help
get the boot of the oppressor off their
neck as hard as we fight for that and as
dedicated as we
are to that and as genuine as we are
about that they're equally as genuine
about their bigotry towards those people